Trump is not happy with this book being
sold at bookstores and I think we ought
to call one two bookstores and see if we
can prank call somebody here this is the
only bookstore we found is in Irvine so
you're making a phone call to a book
store in Irvine let's see what Josh is
gonna be telling these folks guys pay
attention have a special you got to be
quiet yes we will be doing a prank call
for those of you that are they playing
Hawaiian music that's actually Hawaiian
music I'd love to see if they pick up
and see if the people here at Barnes and
Nobles pick up and we're gonna be prank
calling them as Donald Trump I think
they're gonna pick up quickly it's not
Donald Trump but as you see how they
react okay can you do me a favor can you
try to get a hold them on your phone and
when you do bring the phone in because
if I listen to this yes Arianna my name
is Donald I got a quick question for you
is it true you guys got the John Bolton
book is coming in I'm telling you I'd
like to buy all of them okay I'd like to
make sure they don't go to the public
I'm telling you it's all a lie it's a
big lie it's fake news okay so if you
could just put them all on hold for
Donald okay do an Ald yes it's gonna be
1-800 Donald okay it's gonna go straight
to the Trump campaign
okay we'll give you a pasta man thank
you so very much remember don't sell
them okay thank you
[Laughter]
Donald and by the way what's great about
her is she's sitting there debating
saying okay I know this guy's full of it
but if I say anything he can turn on me
so let me just be diplomatic about his
good for husband away good for her for
the way she handled it but uh I think we
should actually send her a gift card we
should send her a gift card oh let's get
the people's perspective on it I'm
Josh's Donald impression that was
amazing
[Music]